we pick up right where we left off
during season one there's no escape for
Georgina she now she's confronted with
the dilemma of how to get away with
murder
not only practically but also her in
terms of her own conscience she returns
to the villa Carmela and he's living
with the Clio's family and watching them
become more and more concerned about the
disappearance of Adam and then has steps
on her she had her stepson who is
murdered so Vanya so and and we
introduced a new family so the EU sense
that the the grapevine is very thick in
the South of France and and within that
society it's very hard to keep secrets
so it's gonna be tricky for for her it's
a lot of contrast isn't it because we've
got these this beautiful scenery this
incredible coastline of the Cote d'Azur
and then this very dark world into which
Georgina is being dragged further and
further and this evolution of her that
the moral decline I suppose we're seeing
so where does that head in series to she
yes she she's now because she was she
was sort of this guileless innocent
optimistic girl who now had all this
tragedy heaped on her and because of her
actions at the end of season one she has
to just put one foot in front of the
other and and she's determined to prove
to herself that she's not a sociopath
but also maintain her power and position
and so she is quite corrupted by the
world that she lives in what stands out
about riviera is that it's the women who
are driving this show is that was that
part of the appeal for you when you saw
the script it was I mean I I couldn't
have anticipated exactly how much this
was going to be about the women of the
Riviera but I I'm so proud to be part of
a show that is something that something
a show like this could so easily be
about the billionaire
and the male businessmen and certainly
we have our girls in bikinis and we have
all the glitz and the glamour but and
women who are rivals with each other but
but really the the powerhouses and the
and the the movers and shakers are the
female characters do you see that as a
trend more and more in TV now we've got
shows like killing Eve fleabag big
little lies to handmaids tales all big
female led narratives I it's exciting
right now as an actress I'm more excited
about the opportunities coming my way
and also for my peers I do think that
that there are some amazing female
driven shows on TV we're joined this
season by Juliet Stevenson who is an
amazing actress and and so you have
Juliet students and Lena all in me and
and other women in the show but I
remember looking at them one day on set
and I was off the women of the Riviera
and it's not it's not we're not just you
know arm-candy or trophies but these are
all women who are the stories are about
the women these women are our forces to
be reckoned with and you talked about
the roles that are coming your way for
for TV what about movies Hollywood slow
to catch up with that when we're talking
about these strong female female led
narratives I don't think so no I'm I
think I mean and when you say Hollywood
I don't think there's really much of but
the line between film and television is
quite blurred now because so much of us
watch both at home and the quality of
television is really on par with film I
think when you look at what you've done
over your career we're talking about the
role of Georgina and you've played a lot
of tough female characters very strong
female characters and you conscious of
the kind of message that you want to
portray through those roles yes yes
[Music]
but I I'm often at a loss when I'm asked
to describe Georgina the the the
character I play in Riviera because
she's so complicated so it's only
mansoni really in hindsight that I can
say how how strong she is or how much of
a backbone she has and I and I do
appreciate showing her vulnerability and
and and her flaws because I don't think
anyone's interested in I'm not
interested in watching a story about
perfect people who make the right
decisions all the time one of your
defining roles and I suppose a defining
role and film for a generation was that
of khatyn 10 Things I Hate About You 20
years old this year and and that was a
film that broke the the 90s rom-com mold
in a way didn't it in the way in which
it portrayed this teenage girl she
didn't have to change the way she was to
attract the guy and it's still relevant
today well and her goal wasn't it to
attract the guy which I thought was an
interesting and new I wanted that part
so badly because it was the first time
that I had read a character of a teenage
girl with who's so feisty and contrarian
yeah and and anti that the film the
narrative the film the anti misogynist
message that it has about it and yet
based loosely on the taming it that's
true which is cherie which is very
misogynistic thanks it is it was written
by 10 Things I Hate About You was
written by two female screenwriters and
I think one of the reasons that it that
it grabbed audiences is because it had a
bite to it and in a way that rom-com
sometimes don't and I'm just it's it's a
wonderful to be a part of a movie that
people are still thinking about 20 years
later and of course of the Bourne movies
as well marking your shift from the teen
rolls into this huge franchise
again something that I couldn't have
anticipated I remember sitting I was in
University and I was sitting in my dorm
room my agents had sent me just this
like the the couple of scenes that I
would have that I would have been
auditioning for in the very first Bourne
movie is a character was originally
killed or she was and we weren't allowed
to see the entire script he was very
secretive I thought it was just going to
be other than one one-off thing and and
and luckily my character they recut it
so my character survived but I didn't
know that it was going to be you know
many many years later that we'd be
making more yeah and what is coming up
next for you hustlers yes I'm really
excited about it we just finished but
it's going to be coming out soon it's a
movie called hustlers and it's based on
a New York magazine article a true story
of these strippers at a club in New York
City who when the stock market crashed
they weren't bringing in as much money
and they decided to start drugging the
men that would come in to the champagne
room and and they ended up running up
hundreds of thousands of dollars in
their credit card tabs up to the point
where they were making millions they
didn't get caught for the longest time
because the men didn't want to come
forward and or couldn't remember what
happened and then eventually they were
caught but I play the New York magazine
journalist who covers the story and
interviews these women and slowly starts
to look at them as entrepreneurs dare I
say fantastic that's alongside JLo cardi
B and you say that's coming out soon and
away from movies who described yourself
as being obsessed with keeping up with
the news you're very politically engaged
you've been vocal about Donald Trump
approval ratings for him at their
highest since he came into office right
now looking ahead to 2020 do you think
he's going to get a second term I mean
if I could predict that I I have no idea
and I had no I I had an inkling that he
was going to win the last time around
and I I'm really at a loss for something
to say because
it's a look of despair it is it is I
mean I would like to I would like to be
optimistic and I would like to think
that there's hope for my country and and
how it affects the rest of the world but
I'm not alone in that country so no I
mean I mean you look at what's going on
in u.s. politics and you look at the
Malheur investigation and talk of
Russian collusion and the Twitter rouse
that are going on I mean it could be a
Hollywood screenplay at the moment
couldn't it I look forward to the day
when it becomes a movie and we can look
back on this fleeting time in US history
I mean I hope that I hope that it is
fleeting I don't know I can't I don't
have a crystal ball so okay fantastic
Julius elves thank you very much indeed
for joining us and series two of Riviere
out on May the 23rd thank you thank you